hi leute ich sie teure mal wanne
unbekannte zu einer neuen folge seine
wills wissen
in dieser partie zwischen probieren wir
erst die haare glätten soll
wie ihr ja und stärken können war ich
wieder besser und er hat nicht nur die
frau geändert sondern hat mir auch
glockenrein gemacht und was wäre so die
bessere voraussetzungen als waffen um
ein neues auszuprobieren
die haare glatt machen sonst das werden
wir jetzt tun
das ist das wo die schrift ist es schon
ordentlich schwer muss ich sagen also
normale haarbürste beste gefühl von 1
also ich muss sagen die verarbeitung
sieht jetzt nicht spektakulär aus ich
bin sehr gespannt ob das meine haare
abbrennt wird oder nächste stecken wir
uns dass man in den stock gleich
explodiert es im deutschen recht ist
explodiert nein es ist nicht explodiert
an knopf
sie weiß jetzt eine anzeige die
temperatur steigt 38 29 12 40 43 40 bis
hin zu danken
warum kannst du stelldichein auf 160
grad
es ist das ganze plastik schmilzt
probier's mal bei 160 okay
na ja mach mal 170 grad
ok also was ja praktisch ist dass das
ein glätteisen plus bürste quasi ist
noch nicht ganz wieder so richtig
funktionieren soll ja wieder eine ganz
erfolgreiche folge nehmen wir noch ein
jahr
ich glaube die böse taugt doch was wenn
man 180 grad mit jetzt handy habe ich
heiß schaut mich an wie schön ich bin
ich könnte mir mein volles haar
man kann sagen dass das schon
funktioniert auch seine art und weise
aber auch dass jetzt das revolutionäre
neue glätteisen ist finde ich nicht also
leute ich empfehle diese bürste nicht
weil sie nicht gut verarbeitet ist uns
das ergebnis nicht möglich dem
entspricht was man erwartet und jetzt
möglich sogar das dickschiff ein
bisschen warm wird an manchen stellen wo
er undicht ist und verpasst auch nicht
die letzten folgen und nicht die noch
kommen werden